مساء الخير من هم مسلمون يا اللي الامم
المتحده اطلقت عليهم مؤخرا
الاقليه الاكثر في العالم واللي حاول شيخ
الازهر من خلال مؤتمر عقد مؤخرا القاهره
حلال ماساتهم للعالم كله بيتحدث عن اسلوب
سموا بهذا الاسم نسبه الى اللغه الذي
يتحدث وهاو هي لغه الرؤيه وت عددهم حوالي
ثلاثه مليون بيعيشوا في اقليم اسمه اركان
او الاثنين الاسمي لنفس الاقليم اللي
موجود في ماينمار على الحدود مع بنغلاديش
والحقيقه بيتعرضوا وفقا ل كافه التقارير
الدوليه اللي كافه انواع الطغاه بكل
اشكاله اذا كان قتل اذا كان بهذا على
الهويه
حرمه من الوظائف حرمان من التعليم حرما من
فرص العمل قيود على السفر حتى الزواج
يحتاجوا في اذن مسبق من السلطات الم سلطات
الاقليم والاهم من كل ده انهم منعوا من حق
الحصول على الجنسيه
ونتيجه عدم ونتيجه وجود قيود على السفر
يتعرضوا الى الوفاء وفي محاولتهم بالهروب
الى دول الجوار التي لا ترحب بهم الاستاذ
المختلفه لازم نعرف انه دوله من الامور
اللي كانت تسمى حتى
1989 برمي مكونه كثير من الدول الجوار من
العراق طوائف مختلفه
وهي فيها حوالي مائه وثلاثه واربعين
سنه
1973 اقرت دوله ماينمار او حكومه م اربعه
قليل وين جات واحد من المكونات العراقيه
المختلفه للدوله لكن تحت ضغوط الاغلبيه
البوذيه التي تنصب هذه الاقليه العداء
لاسباب تاريخيه رجعت الحكومه و سنه
1982 احنا نعترف بس الاقليات اللي موجوده
او اللي جاءت الى ماينمار واستقرت فيه قبل
123 اي اقليه اخرى تاتي بعد هذا التاريخ
لن نعتبرهم من مواطني دوله ماينمار
1823 م مرتبط ب تاريخ الصراع الكبير ما
بين بريطانيا
مسابقه
مع بعض ثلاث حروب كانت اخرها
1826 انتهت باستيلاء بريطانيا على اقليم
اركان او
تحت الاحتلال البريطاني شجع البريطانيه
نزوح عدد كبير جدا من
المسلمين كلهم مسلمين للفلاحين يعني عماله
رخيصه من بنغلاديش في منطقه
فقد ال ال المزارعين الاصليين كثير من فرص
العمل بسبب توافد هؤلاء المهاجرين
وزارت المساله حده بدايه من
1829 هو في الاساس العظيم الى ضرب العالم
كل سنه ثلاثين الثلاث يحصل توتر شديد نريد
اهالي البلد الاصليين وما بين المهاجرين
المسلمين ادى هذا الصراع الى ظهور حركتين
يعني مش في نفس التوقيت لكن تقريبا في
الفتره من سنه ثلاثين سنه
1960 تقريبا واحد وستين الحركه الاولنيه
هي وبورما او نحن بر ما اللي عملها
اهالي البلد من البوذيين ودي حركه قوميه
كره لي المهاجرين غير الشرعيين وكارثه
للاجانب الاجانب من خارج اهل البلد
الاصليين كما يرون هم وتحديدا هذه الاقليه
اللي بيعملوها سبب حر منهم المرافق
ظهرت على اثر الحركه ديه حركه اخرى سمت
نفسها مبرمه كانوا كلهم مسلمين وحول
الانفصال اكثر من مره وخاضوا صناعات كثيره
مع البوذيين في ميانمار
وجزء من مستمر عده سنوات لغايه
الفشل سنه الف وتسعمائه وواحد وستين
الحقيقه ان
الصراع في جزء من ديني وفي جزء من تاريخي
لاسباب اقتصاديه
يعني الصراع في البدايه ما كانش عندهم
مشكله اهالي ماينمار في البدايه ما كانش
عضو الكلام على المسلمين لكن المشكله حصلت
نتيجه استغلال الاحتلال البريطاني لهذه
الاقليه في تنفيذ المشروعات الاقتصاديه
على حساب اهالي ما وبالتالي
ارتبطت مصالح هذه الاقليه ب الاحتلال
البريطاني بريطانيا استغلت هذه الاقليه
كما استغلت اقليات مسلمه كثير في شبه
القاره الهنديه
لاسباب سياسيه تتعلق بين مصالحها في
ان مصالح هذه الاقاليم طبقت الاحتلال
البريطاني فما كان مش متحمسين او لدعوات
اهالي برمه سابقا للاستقلال على الاحتلال
البريطاني دا في الله او الهروب يعتبرهم
انهما طائفه غير وطنيه فضلا عن اصرارها
ليبرمان هؤلاء المهاجرين غير الاصليين
طبعا اهالي او اقليه يا اللي بيقولوا انه
هم مستقرين او على الاقل الكثير منهم
مستقره في مينامار من 1500 و 1600 يعني
كثير لسنوات طويله من الاحتلال الطريق تبع
الاقتصادي في بعد ديني
نتيجه هذه الاقليه المسلمه ابتدى يظهر
البعد الديني في تحديد الطائفه اطلقت على
نفسها
969 ودول مجموعه من
البوذيين عندهم انتماء قوميه
ونصب المسلمين العداء بيعتقدوا انه م
راغبين في السيطره على البلد وفرض اجندتهم
عليهم وفرض اجنده الشريعه الاسلاميه
وتغيير حكم الثقافيه رقم 969 ه مشرقه يعني
يعني مثلا ثلاث سبعات او في الساحه
المصريه وانا في جيش من البيوت لكن ده
اختصارا لمجموعه القيم اللي بتمثل ها
الديانه البوذيه يعني عباره عن تسعه سته
سته خصائص الذين البوذيه 99 وصايه الى اخر
الامر الغريبه انهم اختاروا الاسمده في
مقابل رقم مهم عن بكثير من المسلمين في
شرق اسيا وهو رقم
786 او 78 الرقم ده احنا في المنطقه
العربيه كمسلمين ما نعرفوش وربما اشقائنا
في الخليج يستقبلوا عرض من الوافدين
اسا وين يعرفون شويه لكن الرقم
القصه طويله القصه باختصار انه رقم مرتبط
ب مئات السنين في الماضي لما كان فيه حاجه
اسمها الابجديه الرقميه الرقميه لكل حرف
في اللغه العربيه يقابله رقم يعني الالف
رقم 12 وتفضل كلام التسلسل لطيف الرقم ال
ال الحرفي الحداشر يبتدي ياخذ رقم عشرين
ثلاثين واربعين يعني يعني يزيد عشره مع كل
رقم يعني مثلا بحرف السين وقبل رقم ستين
تبرير رقم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم فكثير من
الاسيويين بيعتبروا الرقم مبارك ورقم مقدس
واحيانا يستخدموه بدل كلمه بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم في الاماكن اللي لا يجب ان
يذكر فيها اسم الله غير حمامات مثلا وشوي
شوي الرقب بالمسلمين واصبح رقم مقدس
للمسلمين هناك وبالمناسبه بسبب حرصه كثير
من الاسيويين الرقم في بعض البلاد
الخليجيه بس تشوف اقبال الاسيويين على
الرقم
مثلا في السيارات او خلاف باليسار اعلى
شويه
في كل الاحوال البوذيين بغير مهتم من كل
القصه هما شايفين ان الرقم 7 86 برقم سري
لما تجمعه يطلع 21 كوب يستخدمه المسلمين
هناك السيطره على العالم وعلى كرمه في
القرن الواحد وعشرين
واصبح صراع
969 في مقابل 786 صراع ما بين بوذيين
ومسلمين
وطبعا ما فيش توازن في القوه الغالبيه
العظمى من المدنيين التاريخ و الجغرافيا و
الاقتصاد و عوامل كثيره ضد هذه الاقليه
المنكسره التي لا يرحب بها اي من الدول
المجاوره
انا احب بس قبل ما ختم اعود واذكركم ان
الرقم 786 هو هو جميل عدد الحروف اللي هي
البسمله يعني لما جمعوا واحد وهو البئر
وسيله وستين الموز اللي مرتبطه الابديه
الرقميه عددهم ان رقم
786 الايضاح الامر الاخير ان استغلال
البريطانيين الاقليات المسلمه في شبه
جزيره
كثير من مستعمره شغلنا له في حلقات اخرى ل
ل يحب تتعرف على اسباب ودوافع هم وان شاء
الله معركه في حلقات اخرى قادمه اشكركم
على لقاء اخر ان شاء الله